you guys clearly have a commanding
presence in the world of finance
people have called you i think it was
chemotherapy called wall street bets the
largest hedge fund in the world now
which is ridiculous
um you've been featured on wall street
um sorry on wall street journal
uh to take uh a name akin to you
bloomberg cnn
um cnbc forbes business insider
the freaking white house was talking
about you guys congress was bringing you
guys up
um what's that all feel like does it
feel like
uh almost like you created this
frankenstein monster and and now you're
just kind of sitting back being like
have at it world what's that worldwide
of emotion actually feel like
look i you know i'll start just by
clarifying something in case uh
you get a lot of haters from this i did
all that is true except that i was
removed
from wall street by reddit last year uh
so so over the past
12 or so months i've not uh been a
moderator on wall street best but the
rest of the things that you said
very much written true wall street bets
is it's
the the forum itself has a commanding
presence has a lot of
uh followers to it and they're
definitely
on everybody's radar as you mentioned
but wall street bets
is an idea and there's an empowerment of
people everywhere is spilling out all
over the place
you'll see offshoots of wall street vets
will it change this so wall street
silver
or satoshi street bets you know for
crypto stuff
uh and and other ones and i think that
this this idea of empowerment
and it's what's propagated around the
world is is
the the most unexpected but also the the
most wonderful part about this like
after
gamestop took place i got messages i
would say i got more messages from
people
outside of the us from countries where
they don't really have access to the
stock market their own stock market
where they don't have the ability to
replicate or do anything but that
enthusiasm for saying hey i'm in the
netherlands or spain or
korea we want to do that here in fact
there is now korea street vets and india
street vets and they're all wanting to
do that because that sense of
empowerment
uh is is something that is powerful it's
something that the occupy wall street
movement failed to do they're all
sitting there where they're picking
signs they're saying 99
it's not fair the one percent now all of
a sudden 99
say okay the pickets didn't seem to work
now we're going to pick at their pockets
and see if that works and that does and
it's in this completely
forced comments like this from the
warren buffett's in the world it's
forced
politicians like it politicians are like
hell yeah now it's their time to finally
speak you know ted cruz and
uh aoc were retweeting each other about
the fact that like they're getting
they're agreeing on something they're
getting along all this
and because of you man because of you
and and it's it's it's really cool no so
i i
very very much enjoyed the fact that
people
uh have been able to empower themselves
with knowledge with the ability to to
speak their voice in a different way
than just
voting they can now vote with their
wallets right without having to
donate to super pacs or to donate to the
local congressman they can now vote with
their wallets by saying okay i'm going
to change these prices i don't think
short selling is a good idea so we're
going to show you how we feel about that
uh and end up costing these people money
so i think that is
uh i i think that's a wonderful
wonderful thing you know
as far as for for me personally i i'm
enjoying watching it like the the
other than getting the attention being
able to to have these great
conversations with people i haven't
really
had any personal gains in fact i had a
really funny story i was in
in miami a couple weeks ago and uh
i'm in a big shopping mall my
brother-in-law calls me up and he says
oh you're in the u.s hey listen i'm
dying to get a hold of a
playstation all right like it's really
hard to get ahold of you think you can
like i'm on a tight schedule and i'm
kind of looking around i'm like but
maybe tomorrow
and as i'm doing this i look up and i
see a game stop and i'm like hold on
i think i got this i got an idea i'll
i'll call you right back
so i go up to the game stop and i walk
past the store and i look into it and i
see some old little
lady like work at the register and
that's it so i'm like nah nah she's not
gonna know what's up
i'll come back later if i come back
later and i see a guy that's a
little younger over much younger it's
like a young guy right there i'm like
he's gonna definitely know as i'm
walking in this store i see these big
signs that applies to says we don't have
any causals don't even waste our time
blah blah blah you know and so i go
to this guy i'm like hey i uh i read the
signs on the thing and
and you may and i know you're not
supposed to ask for these consoles but
but i think my request might be special
like um what if i told you that i
founded wall street vets
and i have my mask on you know and he's
got his mask on or whatever nobody can
see each other and he goes oh that's
fine again
sorry no console dude like no no
seriously i i really did
did start wall street bets i can prove
it i have like you know verified
accounts on twitter there
or on instagram i had the twitter
account whatever it is like just google
my name or whatever
dude that's funny like i've heard a lot
of really good excuses but this this one
this one takes the cake like dude i
swear to god it's me like
look sorry i muted my mug there so i say
so i say and it goes all right let's say
i believe you
i still don't you know we there's still
nothing i can do it's like well
just think outside the box man like
don't you have a manager or someone that
can really use like the
publicity i'll i'll plug you guys i'll
tweet whatever
you know some of these got decision
making power he's like yeah no
sorry dude take care
so so not even that was i able to get
with this oh dude i thought that story
was going in a different i thought he
had like the one magical playstation
the personal benefits to me or not the
personal benefits to the world
were wonderful but uh but as far as i'm
concerned like
not even a police station you're a
philanthropist in that regard
dude that's like the perfect open like
it's like the perfect investing joke
where the founder of wall street bets
walks into a game stop
tries to get himself a playstation turns
out he got hedge fund and he couldn't
buy the dip
and he had to walk out the exit took a
loss
but uh he's there for the the greater
good of humanity
i think that's that's got a certain
genesee quote to it